forget Fashion Week what do you know  about the royal family of Aldo via the  king died last year and the prince who's  supposed to take over as a total slave  and scandalous socialite why me you're  talented hungry smart and none of my  regular writers can go this week  this assignment could jumpstart your  career  and actually inside the palace this is  better than exclusive get lots of video  audio whatever you can grab hi you seen  Bella fascination with my brother I  heard people say you didn't want to give  up your lifestyle what lifestyles that I  don't know women lion and song is that  what nice okay  I don't really know who you are  I hope you come tomorrow night tomorrow  night Christmas Eve boo what's going on  complete makeover  [Music]  are you waiting for  [Music]  why are they staring does he live  perfect  [Music]  palaces many place for okay without  going  [Music]  you